far back as I can remember I always
wanted to be a gangster so you want to
make a Martin Scorsese film well you
came to the right place trying to make a
picture like the master himself is a
difficult task but I am confident that
with these simple tips you'll be on your
way to making a very own Rolling Stones
filled classic disappearing
Mickey's name was in every one of those
newspapers when you're making a Scorsese
picture you're not just making a movie
you are making art but not a student
film art house piece I'm talking about
something artistic enough to be
intelligent but also stay mainstream
it's a delicate balance so listen
carefully first off you're gonna need to
grab your trusty Leonardo DiCaprio Oh
your mother must be a wonderful woman
look clean to you the hell you voice
smoking over there Oh Robert De Niro you
love someone you've got to trust them
talking to me already rhythm yeah nobody
copy besides these guys are your Swiss
Army knife of cast members they can look
and act like anyone then just sprinkle
in some of your Italian regulars Oh
Frank tell me tell me what's funny the
first time I ever saw you guys together
a blonde leading lady yep there's nothin
coming fired
what's wrong dad two good people working
for us really freaking me out right now
just a friend of mine I was trying to
help and your parents and you're good to
go now this brings us to the script the
term original content is such an
ambiguous word that gets thrown around a
lot these days it's best if you pull
your story directly from the pages of
real life or at least from the pages of
someone else's book
nothing will get asses in seats more
than a film that profits from the
glorification of real-life criminals
it's like stealing candy from a baby
or at least making a movie about a guy
who does what are the last acceptable
racism's is the Italian stereotype take
advantage of that give your characters
hot tempers what a great tragedy honey
oh my god
I don't fuck my funny what the fuck is
so funny about me you never even loved
me in the first place
and United effect is it make them
amazing cooks that's best way to fry up
before dinner just as an appetizer going
over cookie over focus notebook
pretty much everyone should kiss each
other because solo under doesn't Pete
agree and don't forget they must be
religious Hey hey rise rise Paul fuck
are you doing you can give generously to
the church for the Lord crushes the
wicked not worth it to drink your blood
well I can't cock before him Scorsese
appears in many of his films follow his
example so your face will be more widely
known have a girl right so my father no
others dick and everything we had let's
go right at the moment except once
you're on set the most important thing
to do is to keep the film raw you want
to make sure you're capturing the most
real and powerful takes even if that
means not cutting when actors look
directly at the camera or when the
camera ends up in the shots except we
miss long you what could I use your
phone some great tools you can use if
your movie is not making any sense of
post-production are freeze frames my
name is Jordan Belfort
but after a while
voiceover I don't want to be a product
of my environment Paulie didn't talk to
six people
Pamela there's not much of a difference
anyway is there especially that the boss
has made the Teamsters lent him the
money are working their magic on Donnie
right now finally you should use your
movies to take out your pent-up
aggression that is deep inside of you
most likely from several years of
cocaine usage you can do this by
including massive amounts of drugs
domestic violence
wake up you should have come in people
being shot at point-blank range
and an exuberant amount of words this
thank your mother sucks in big fucking
elephant dicks yeah and that's it follow
these simple instructions and you'll be
on your way to creating a very own
Martin Scorsese film